Hey, welcome.
And in this video, we're just gonna have a look
at how you can use the new ChatGPT desktop application.
Okay, so to download ChatGPT for your desktop,
go to openai.com slash chatgpt slash desktop.
I'll put that link in this video,
and you can download it for either your macOS or Windows.
All right, so now that ChatGPT desktop is open,
there's a couple of different things
I'd like to point out here.
You've got your chat history on the left hand
that you can see here.
If you go down to the bottom left and you click on settings,
a settings panel will load,
and you can optimize and improve the experience.
So for example, you can say
whether you want to use for chat training,
you can also do things like customize your ChatGPT
so you can add on custom instructions.
So that can be quite nice.
And you can also turn on or off
different types of GPT for capabilities.
So you can see we've got browsing, delay, and code.
So these are the types of things
you can optimize in the settings.
The other thing that's good to know
is there's a keyboard shortcut for the desktop launcher.
So this is useful for when you're creating,
when you're wanting to launch it.
And also you can choose a different voice.
So you can choose between Ember, Juniper,
Breeze, or Cove at the moment.
I personally really like Juniper's voice.
And this is one of the benefits
of using ChatGPT on desktop
is you can do voice conversation.
If you look at the bottom,
we can click on the headphones
and then ChatGPT will enter a voice communication.
And we can talk to ChatGPT in real time.
And so now ChatGPT,
you're just being talked about on a course.
So how does that make you feel ChatGPT?
I'm glad to hear that prompt engineering courses
are becoming more popular.
It's an important skill for getting the most out of AI.
What kind of things are they covering in the course?
Oh, we're covering quite a lot.
And so thanks for having that chat with us, ChatGPT.
So when you're finished with ChatGPT,
if you look in the top, you can click on the pause.
And then after that,
you can also cancel it as well.
So the way I like to do it is I like to pause it in the top
and then I like to go to the top left.
And then you'll now see that you've got a voice chat
that's just ended.
And what's interesting about this
is basically you have your voice chat here
and you can see all the messages
that we were talking about with ChatGPT.
One thing that you can do as well
is you can have a voice conversation with ChatGPT,
but then in a separate window on the browser,
you can have a different ChatGPT session going.
And this can be quite useful.
So for example, we can have one window
where we're using ChatGPT and we're using it to do text,
another where we're just using ChatGPT to keep us company
or to bounce ideas off immediately.
So that can be quite useful.
So for example, we can spin up a chat session here
and at the same time say,
we're currently learning about prompt engineering.
Learning about prompt aspects of prompt engineering,
are you focusing on right now?
So I'm just gonna pause ChatGPT
and then what I want you to see
is if I refresh this browser,
you'll see ChatGPT has given us some information
on the tags.
But if I rephrase this browser, refresh this browser,
you'll see that we've also got
prompt engineering basics as well.
And so when we end this chat session,
this will also appear up as a separate one.
So what you'll see is the voice chat ended
and then you've got this one here.
So this exciting one here
and this is the one we're talking about.
So what I want you to think about
is you could be talking to ChatGPT as you work,
but then you could be using a separate tab
specifically for doing other tasks.
So you can have both the voice interaction
and the text interaction
in two separate chat windows simultaneously.
The latency of voice is gonna be reduced significantly.
So when that model comes out,
you might find that it's even faster
to talk to ChatGPT via voice chats.
A final feature that I wanna talk to you about in ChatGPT
is ChatGPT's ability to easily take screenshots.
You can do this on Macintosh
by holding the alt or option in space.
And then this will load a window
that you can see here in the middle of the screen.
When you have this window open,
you can easily send messages to ChatGPT.
But one of the killer features that I found to be useful
is clicking on this attachment icon
and clicking take screenshot or take photo.
Let's now upload a screenshot of my Spotify application.
Take a screenshot and tell to ChatGPT
what is the song that I am currently listening to.
What we can do here is we can specifically upload
attachments based on our screenshot.
And we can send vision directly to Spotify.
And just to show you what I was listening to,
I was listening to Holy Diver, Kill Switch, Engage.
And you can see that ChatGPT was able to easily take
a bit of a screenshot of one of my applications,
which is my Spotify playlist.
And then what it allows it to do is then
we can then ask you questions about that.
So a really great killer feature,
you just hit that option space or hold space.
And then you go to the attachment icon.
And then you can take a screenshot
of any of your applications or your entire screen
on the specific application
that you'd like to ask questions about.
That screenshot will then allow ChatGPT's vision model
to answer questions about that image.
Cool, so hopefully you learned a lot about
how you can use the ChatGPT desktop application.